contingency plans that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
now government's filled with sneaky
cowards isn't it and this week Senate
Republicans hit speaker McCarthy's
decision to Green Light an impeachment
inquiry and they did so via Anonymous
comments to journalists calling
impeachment a Fool's errand a waste of
time even comparing impeachment to a
binky for conservative house members and
Democrats are sneaky too just ask former
Trump National Security adviser Mike
Flynn what he went through when the
Obama Intel Community wanted to take
Flynn out they came at him sideways
through Washington Post columnist David
Ignatius it turns out that someone in
the Intel Community gave that Rider a
heads up about calls that were
intercepted between Flynn and the
Russian Ambassador at the end of 2016.
like clockwork this ended up in a column
published on January 12 2017 where
Ignatius noted the Flynn calls and then
asked did Trump's campaign encourage
Russia's alleged hacking to hurt his
rival Hillary Clinton and help him and
does Russia have any Leverage over him
well we know the rest of the story a
special counsel was appointed to
investigate Russian election
interference and Flynn eventually pled
guilty Ignatius was the go-to guy to get
the ball rolling
so I wondered is a similar Dynamic at
play again but this time the guy they're
trying to push aside could it be Joe
Biden in a Washington Post column
published two days ago Ignatius a loyal
Democrat argues that Biden should not
run again
Biden's age isn't just a Fox News Trope
it's been the subject of dinner table
conversations Across America this summer
Kamala Harris Harris is less popular
than Biden she's failed to gain Traction
in the country or even within her own
party wow
and he sounded the alarm again on camera
through this summer I haven't gone
anywhere in the country I haven't talked
to any group of people
where this issue of whether President
Biden should run again hasn't been a
centerpiece conversation it doesn't get
into the the newspapers
but it's there now which leads us to ask
is there some coordination going on
between top government officials who are
increasingly worried about a trump
second term and the Press who equally
despises Trump and is getting worried
have they now made a calculation that
Biden is a liability and not an asset
and are they now kind of feeling their
way to some type of transition away from
Biden
I asked Nancy Pelosi who in two
consecutive media appearances sounded
purposely unconvincing and her faint
praise for a Biden Harris ticket
the Biden Harris team is a team we're
very proud of Joe Biden is bringing such
wisdom judgment experience to the job of
presidency and he is a great president
and will continue to be a great
president he's experienced and strategic
in his thinking that's all up here and
then in the heart he's the most
empathetic president
yeah the fire victims in Maui thought
Joe Biden was super empathetic when he
finally visited the region the deadliest
fire in State history and then he
Compares it to an old kitchen fire we
almost lost his cat
Pelosi's absurd praise makes Biden seem
even more decrepit to me at least not
less and I think she knows that too she
has to say those things and she also
knew that the message she was about to
be sending about Biden's number two was
going to be taken a certain way when she
answered this question
the best running mate for this president
he thinks so and that's what matters and
by the way I think so she's very
politically astute I don't think people
give her enough credit
now no one who follows politics believes
that Pelosi who herself is extremely
astute thinks Kamala is anything but a
liability at this point and her feigned
attempt with Anderson Cooper to praise
Harris is just another sign that the
Democrats are getting very very nervous
Nancy wants Democrats to take the house
back of course and who knows she may
even want to wrestle that gavel from
Hakeem Jeffries in 2025. I don't know
and does she think a Biden Harris ticket
Nancy Pelosi with all of her experience
that ticket is her best chance at
getting that power back
don't think so and Pelosi is not the
only one who seems to be between the
lines equivocating
do you think Kamala Harris is the best
running mate for president Biden that's
President Biden's choice and I think
she's an excellent running mate uh for
President Biden
um you know I don't know what more needs
to be said about that I actually think
it's a pretty simple question do you
think Kamala Harris is the best running
mate for president Biden yes or no I
mean I don't know what else I can say
other than she you can say yes excellent
running mate and an excellent vice
president
um I don't know whether President Biden
has named his uh running mate we're
going to a convention uh next summer
it's a you know a year away from now
um and we're going to go through that
process
uh
it sounds like the Democrats may be
talking about contingency plans behind
closed doors don't you think
perhaps what we're missing though is
that things are actually much much worse
with Biden when the Democrats interact
with him behind closed doors
for instance does anyone believe this
when we're with the president he's
vigorous he's on top of the situation he
is so knowledgeable and you you would
see him meet somebody and say tell me
how your younger son is and I know he
was going to college he has a great
memory which is part of uh
something that might be in question as
as time goes by
what is she kidding me because Biden
sucks up to people about their kids he's
definitely fit for office you can go
into any nursing home and find people
who can do family Chit Chat
again Pelosi knows that Biden is a
figurehead that he's incapable of making
any real decisions on his own they don't
even want him to make those decisions
but even still they'll stick with him if
they think he's their best chance to
beat Trump but if they determine that
Biden is a liability they're going to
dump him one Democrat Oracle David
Ignatius as I said thinks that Biden's a
liability but the widely respected
Pelosi is still on the fence
but what neither perhaps is seeing is
that the walls are closing in not just
on this issue of Biden's age or Biden's
mental Fitness but on his policies
the White House has lied about the
economy it's in shambles
they lied that Biden wasn't aware of
Hunter's foreign money Trail
they lied about the Border it's a
nightmare
they told us a fairy tale about the war
in Ukraine and it's not going well
and now they've backed themselves into a
corner not only with their policies that
are failing but with their candidate
who's failing
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else